[Musique]
on soir mes petits amis
décidément mirabel et p'tit louis sont
vraiment très sage roman j'espère que
vous aussi vous faites plaisir à vos
parents ont dit oui oui d'accord entendu
gros source
mais ne me fait pas attendre toujours
nos propos
[Musique]
moi j'avoue je me présente pas bon je
coiffe matin pour ça
[Musique]
une très belle histoire que je m'en vais
vous raconter
il y avait une fois une petite fleur
appelé crocus qui habitait dans une
petite maison tout noir sous la terre il
y avait bien longtemps qu'ils étaient là
ce petit crocus depuis l'automne et il
avait très froid car c'était l'hiver il
s'ennuyait beaucoup il était tout seul
et il trouver l'hiver bien non un jour
il entendit frapper à sa porte
topp qui est la demande intime c'est moi
la pluie qui voudraient bien entré lui
répondit une petite fille
non non nous on n'entre pas dit le petit
crocus et on ne le dérange à pluie
pendant très longtemps et le petit
crocus s'ennuyait chaque jour d'abord
puis un beau matin
on fera pas de nouveau à sa porte toc
toc qui est là c'est moi le soleil il
répondit un gentil petit garçon non non
on n'entre pas encore répondu andésite
ans le petit crocus puis quelques jours
plus tard
toc toc toc qui l'aiment là
c'est la pluie et le soleil
le soleil et la pluie crièrent ensemble
les deux petits enfants et nous voulons
autres et oui si vous êtes tous les deux
ensemble je vous ouvre la porte
le petit crocus ouvrit la porte avec
beaucoup de peine car il avait encore
les mains engourdis par le froid la
pluie et le soleil entrèrent dans la
maison bonjour petit crocus la pluie lui
pris la main droite
le soleil la main gauche et l'ordr vite
vite jusqu'en haut
et là ils lui dirent passe la tête à
travers la terre et le petit crocus
passe à sa tête et voilà il était au
milieu d'un beau jardin
il n'y avait pas encore d'autres fleurs
car il était le premier à être l'or et
quand les enfants arrivent ère pour le
regarder
ils se mirent à chanter bravo bravo
l'hiver est bientôt fini vive le
printemps qui approche et tous les
petits oiseaux le salut maire d'anchamps
temps et le soleil réchauffe à sa petite
tête pâle
l'histoire est finie
[Musique]
il était touché et va pas non ils
avaient tous ses amis les oiseaux près
de lui et il savait que toutes les
autres fleurs à les sortir de terre très
bientôt
hulu je suis encore en retard je vais me
faire broder par ulysse
alors les enfants chez vous vite revoir
[Musique]
demain à dumas voix
bonne nuit petit louis
boni mirabel boni tous les enfants
en dormez-vous vite on reviendront vous
voir demain bonne nuit
à deux mains
[Musique]
où